more confrontational what is more
confrontational than that are you going
to start releasing biological weapons
are you going to start detonating nukes
hard to get more confrontational than
burning the country down
the left is also going to be permitting
and even encouraging
radicals and terrorists to go out in the
streets and commit
political violence that's exactly what
maxine waters just did
she instructed her followers
to riot if derek chauvin the cop in
minneapolis is not convicted of murder
it was a very difficult case to make
there's really no evidence he committed
murder
and if he is not convicted maxine waters
says
burn the country down we have been
fighting for so many years for reform
reform reform
and so yes i would like to see
the bill in congress pass on police
reform
but i know that the right wing the
racist
are opposed to it and i don't know
what's going to happen to it
but i know this we've got to stay in the
street
and we've got to we've got to demand
justice we're
looking for a guilty verdict we got to
stay on the street
uh and we've got to get more active
we've got to get more
confrontational we've got to make sure
that they
they know that we need business there it
is there's
that confrontational so maxine waters
has already
in the past gotten in trouble for saying
she hasn't gotten in real
trouble she's just gotten a few bad
headlines but she never has actually
held the consequence
she says when you see republicans when
you see people in this administration
you get in their face you mob on them
you get up on you go to their homes
right so she's already saying that what
happened
last year people who tend to support
maxine waters
burned down the country burned down
private businesses
burn down government buildings coast to
coast
and now maxine waters is saying we need
to get
more confrontational more
confrontational
what what is more confrontational than
that are you going to start releasing
biological weapons
are you going to start detonating nukes
hard to get more confrontational than
burning the country down
but that's what maxine waters is going
to call for and it's okay coronavirus
isn't going to spread during those riots
remember
that is what the liberal establishment
told us last year at the height of the
coronavirus panic
at the height of the hysteria a bunch of
radical leftists
led by black lives matter and antifa
went out into the streets and we were
told no that's fine that doesn't spread
coronavirus
actually it's good there was a letter
signed by
over a thousand public public health
officials whatever that means
saying that that
if you went out to protest white
supremacy that was actually helping
the coronavirus mitigation effort
because you see
white supremacy is a lethal public
health threat
meaningless words that are merely used
as instruments to exert one's will
totally unreasonable will the
anglo-saxon political tradition
tends to frown on street violence
the the anglo-saxon tradition from which
we get our political tradition it tends
to not look so kindly
on criminals running roughshod over the
law
in the streets maxine waters loves
criminals and street violence she loves
it she's encouraging it and she's been
encouraging it for a long time
which way you gonna go america those
those are the two choices
and it's it's not
even enough that the street criminal
side of the political question is
winning
it's that even the putatively
conservative republican leaders
are giving cover to the street violence
people and attacking their own side
that they'll you know they'll fight back
a little bit they'll try to against
the street violence people but really
they spend most of their energy going
after the people who want to conserve
that political tradition
wait wait wait wait don't nope nope do
not
not yet you can't go until you
smash that subscribe button you hit that
like button
you got to do it okay or for other
channels
it's totally cool youtube they love
those channels they promote them all the
time
for us maybe they don't like exactly
what we're saying so head on over
make sure you subscribe and never miss a
[Music]
video
[Music]
[Music]
you